[Music]
this is rolling through the bed it is I
believe the world's largest functioning
toothpick sculpture it's got over a
hundred thousand pieces of toothpick and
it has five ping-pong ball tours at roll
to San Francisco because my family has
been Cisco if evolved since I was eight
years old
shear a fanatical desert sculptures in
school and I went home and wanted to
build the biggest one in class and I
kept going I built my own little
abstract sculpture and then I made a
bridge and I put a ball on it and then
that started it the sculpture is kind of
a life story of me it is unique in that
matter because there's times that I was
born my wife was born my mother was born
my grandmother's house 5:18 12th Avenue
it has my face looking up into the
Transamerica building kind of like as of
my vision I have raised going out of my
eyes all the parts are out of our out of
scale so it's kind of cartoony whimsical
as far as I know no one's done a
toothpick sculpture with a ping-pong
ball will won't do it so it is unique I
think I don't think anyone's done
something like this
in building pieces in order to get all
the angles right and stuff I'll build a
piece separate from the sculpture and
then install it with toothpicks brace it
and then make the path roll through it
and then clip the toothpicks away to
make it look nice as a piece of art the
whole sculpture is taken about three
thousand hours in a very long span of 35
years because there are many years I
took time off never thought of money
building the sculpture I've always just
built it to create and to blow people's
minds just to let people think what can
be done out of thousands of hours a box
of toothpicks some Elmer's glue and just
creating having fun
you
[Applause]